[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight and Tifa went on the attack in
Portland Oregon yesterday one of the
victims who was bashed by them joins us
just ahead with an account of what
happened
but first tonight it's been a bewilder
in couple of months for Bill Barr
imagine you're bill bar bar first served
as attorney general in the George HW
Bush administration that was 1991
Alexandria Kazuya Cortez had just turned
two years old at the time that's how
long ago it was
then this February purely by process of
elimination basically cuz he was the one
guy who could get confirmed Barr became
Attorney General of the United States
once again the modern investigation was
nearly over when he got the job Barr
probably didn't expect to become a major
figure in the Russia story because he
had nothing to do with it as far as we
know Barr never met with secret agents
in Prague he never texted Vladimir Putin
on his Blackberry he never managed a
Macedonian content form
if Barr betrayed this country for a sack
of rubles or a case of vodka
nobody has ever proved it but it doesn't
matter the Russia story cannot die CNN
The Washington Post the Democratic Party
many others have too much invested in
that story the fact it's been proven to
be untrue is irrelevant to them bill
Barr is a handy way to keep Russia in
the news watch today's talking point in
action somewhere in the basement of the
Democratic National Committee some
messaging consultant has decided that
credibility is the most effective line
of attack watch we're now joining the
chorus of Democrats saying he should
resign why well first of all his
credibility was shredded yesterday
he played a home game today and his
credibility was destroyed this attorney
general lacks all credibility he's
burned through any credibility he had in
that role and he should resign what we
have here is what we always have here
every single time we have projection
they call you what they themselves are
whether it's privileged or bigoted or
hateful or in this case fraudulent these
are the same people who spent two full
years ginning up hysteria over a bogus
story
but it's the rest of us they tell us
with a straight face who lack
credibility these the people who hated
the results of a democratic election so
much that they dropped everything and
worked tirelessly for years in order to
nullify that election so guess what
they're calling other people tonight
enemies of democracy the Attorney
General joined with his supervisor the
president United States decided to show
the American people that this is not a
democracy stop this attack on our
republic and save this nation it's
democracy is simply another step in the
administration's growing attack on
American democracy this is a grave
danger for American democracy and it is
part of the attack on American democracy
by this administration English is the
largest language in the history of the
world more nouns more adjectives more
verbs in any language ever and yet night
after night we managed to find tape of
people saying exactly the same thing
almost like it's coordinated tonight
it's they're attacking our democracy
says the guy who refuses to wait until
the next election to throw out the
elected president okay it went on like
this today and on and on Democrats
stopped in the end trying to make a
rational case for their position or even
use words by the end they were resorting
to prop comedy
here's Congressman Steve Cohen of
Memphis you're looking at images of you
at that Committee hearing today with
what appears to be a bucket of fried
chicken and oh there it is you brought
props I see with you here what is the
message you're trying to send the
message is that bill borrows a chicken
he was chicken to come to the House
Judiciary Committee he does not deserve
respect
he has lowered the bar for lawyers and
for the Attorney General he deserves no
respect he's lowered the bar says the
guy who just brought a bucket of fried
chicken onto the House floor so how long
does this circus continue and by the way
why is it still in progress why hasn't
it left town yet